Bộ Thằng Thư, các ngon tiền và thông tổn rời tư cho biết,
tổn thống Mỹ đồn thành trăm được cho là đăng tân nhất một cải tổn nội gác sau khi bộ trưởng
từ pháp pham bón đi bị bánh nhận trong mối cảnh át dụ chính trị từ vột chiến với iran gia tăng.
Theo các ngon thảo tin, đồng thấy này nhằm tại thế thình ảnh nhà trắng khi chế sự kéo dài đã dẩy giả như lượng tăng,
làm giảm tí lệ ủng hộ và về lòng nạn cho đảng cộng hà trước bộ cử giữa kỳ.
Một số quan trức các cao trong lòng gó giảm đốc tình mà hút ra tương xí gà bác và bộ trưởng thương mại hố lúc lúc lịch
được cho là có nghĩa bị thái thế, dụ trường có quy định quý cộng.
Dụ như trắng khẳng định tổn thống vẫn hoạt toàn tí tưởng và thêm viên lỗi gác,
nhưng một tiên cho rằng khả năng biểu trình đến sự đã trưởng nên gió giảm hơn trong tổn gần đây,
với su hướng thay đổi có trận lọc thay vì cải tổn rời.